6 45 on back to school monday how about  a different perspective on those school  zone speeders  so instead of pounding over the head  again with the same old message  the metro police twitter account put out  a video from  the kids point of view  what the heck  give us a break slow down  [Music]  i just got a big time ticket hey  everybody this is school zone  give us a break for the kid give us a  break and the ladies not lying it's a  big time ticket  complete coverage of back to school day  one throughout the day on 8 news now  buckle up drive carefully please put  down that  phone if there is something driving you  crazy email me traffic 8  8newsnow.com